[Musik]
ich bin nicht wirklich gut im
vorhersagen der zukunft aber klar es
gibt naturkatastrophen und ich wusste
auch es könnte wieder krieg oder einer
pandemie geben
darauf war ich immer vorbereitet
[Musik]
und da passierte es wirklich ich hatte
es nicht erwartet wusste aber aus der
geschichte dass es so kommen könnte
was immer in der vergangenheit geschah
kann wieder passieren
wir waren mit dem wohnmobil unterwegs
arizona war einer unserer stopps dann
kam kobe 19
wir dachten bleiben wir doch hier für
ein paar wochen und sehen mal wie es
weitergeht
doch es wurde nicht besser da wussten
wir jetzt ist vielleicht ein guter
moment sesshaft zu werden
wir kauften dieses stück land das war
vor einem halben jahr die großstadt als
gegenentwurf zum rückzug in die weiten
des westens eine option fit bleiben in
der großstadt eine andere
an der ostküste der usa spürt man den
drohenden kollaps zweifellos stärker
hier ist james wollten vom bremer
broadcasting network moderator des
programms ich bin die freiheit
es ist schwer sich umzusehen und nicht
zu dem schluss zu kommen da kommt ein
großes problem auf uns zu wer fühlt sich
zurzeit nicht ein wenig überfordert
also hast du einen plan für das
amerikanische chaos
die reiterstatue des südstaaten generals
robert l
und wie sie zum zentrum von protesten
wurde hat viel mit der presse
philosophie von james wollten zu tun
natürlich hat das mit beim treppen geht
es darum unsicherheit ziel sei es dass
sie aus der natur kommt sei es aufgrund
gesellschaftlicher oder politischer
probleme
als rapper beobachtest du die
bedrohungslage ganz genau
ehrlich gesagt wenn man sich die
derzeitige situation ansieht ist eine
sehr reale bedrohung zu erkennen
es wird zu gewalt kommen
hier lagern wir unsere lebensmittel und
rapper sachen alle proper und
präparieren haben eines gemeinsam das
anlegen von vorräten ist für sie die
wichtigste überlebensstrategie das kann
man auch mit einem bügeleisen oder einem
haarglätter einschweißen hallo leute ich
bin morgen und das sind meine kinder
mehr als zehn jahre erfahrung fließen
bei mir in meinen blog und meine website
ein und ich bringe mein wissen in meiner
online kurse viele haben erkannt dass
sie sich nicht genügend vorbereitet
hatten viele freunde von mir haben diese
knappheit an lebensmitteln und anderen
dingen erlebt sie waren zornig dass sie
keine eier oder andere
grundnahrungsmittel kaufen konnten
sie sagten sich so etwas soll mir nie
wieder passieren
menschen geraten in panik und werden
verrückt in so eine panik will ich nicht
geraten ich will vorbereitet sein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja es kann tatsächlich vorkommen dass
knappheit herrscht wir jedoch mussten
kein klopapier kaufen als das alles
begann
wir mussten keine konservendosen oder
andere dinge kaufen wir hatten das alles
bereits wir waren vorbereitet nicht
speziell für diese krise sondern ganz
allgemein ein echter präparat auch
gemüse an
am liebsten zusammen mit anderen als
rapper denkt man immer wasser habe ich
lebensmittel auch alle möglichen sachen
was sich jedoch nicht habe sind andere
menschen
deshalb habe ich einen
gemeinschaftsgarten gegründet um die
leute aus der nachbarschaft dazu zu
bringen miteinander zu kommunizieren
ich wollte etwas auf die beine stellen
das nicht zu politisch macht denn davon
haben die leute hier schon genug und die
menschen hier sehr perfekt um sich mit
ihnen zu verbünden
so wie jeder mensch verschieden ist ist
auch jeder bremer verschieden
es gibt es gibt den einsamen wolf der
sich in die berge zurück zieht man kann
alles mögliche tun
je nach glauben oder wie intensiv man
sich vorbereiten will
man kann gar nichts falsch machen tools
wie du willst
[Musik]
die in dem wir uns auf den weltuntergang
vorbereiten schaffen wir eigentlich eine
gute basis für die zukunft
es ist sehr befriedigend fähigkeiten die
wir vergessen haben wieder zu entdecken
tausende von jahren haben wir sie zu
nutzen haus innerhalb von 100 jahren
haben wir sie dann vergessen es ist
wirklich seltsam so etwas wie will der
medizin gibt es einfach nicht mehr
man weiß auch nicht mehr was ein baum
ist und was er kann
das ist alles so rasch vergessen wollen
damals waren wir darauf angewiesen um zu
überleben
doch diese fähigkeiten bietet zeigt
decken wird uns eine bessere zukunft
bringen
training für den ernstfall oder einfach
nur spiel mit der zukunft trepper lassen
sie an sich herankommen
sie fühlen sich prepared
[Musik]